tens of millions of TV viewers are
preparing to watch the Superbowl on
Sunday and nearly half are expected to
be female but a growing number of women
want to be more than just fans this
season the NFL struggled with its
response to player protests and cases of
domestic violence and sexual harassment
well now it's working to get more women
working in the league Jan Crawford
visited with a group of women looking to
change the game she's standing on a
football field in Washington Jenn good
morning burning calories hey Jan well
good morning I'm burning some calories
right so you know from high school to
college all the way up to the NFL
football sidelines are dominated by men
but increasingly across the country the
game is being played coached and managed
by women and now the NFL is putting
these women on a path to a career in the
game they love these girls battling it
out here in Orlando don't see football
as a sport Oh even less than a football
field away 50 women selected from
hundreds of applicants are fighting for
a career on a field traditionally run by
men they haven't had women in these
meetings before and doctor is a lifelong
Minnesota Vikings fan and one of the
pioneers rising for an executive
assistant to the team's director of
football administration I've been
challenged about the fact that I want to
do this job to my face you know I've had
people say why do you want to do this
and why not is what I say back I think
that a lot of women think that that it's
not a possibility or not something they
would naturally consider doing because
they don't see other women doing it
women make up roughly half of all NFL
fans currently just a third of League
employees and there have been no female
head coaches or general managers the
players already know how to deal with
women in that workspace Carolina
Panthers head coach Ron Rivera has seen
firsthand another issue the league's
struggles with workplace misconduct this
year Panthers owner Jerry Richardson was
forced to step aside appointing Tina
Becker now one of the NFL's top female
executives as his replacement there are
jobs for women involved in the NFL and
they're not on the outside they're in
the inside
making decisions push yourself in the
two-day forum the women are learning the
finer points of coaching scouting
players the importance of dreaming big
if you know what the dream chuckle is
let me see your hand
that's kind of when you tell people your
dreams and they kind of go huh that's
good yeah congratulations mine is more
of a like a hysterical I'm sat down with
for the women to talk about breaking
through football's gender barrier big
picture I like to be a GM being a
majority owner and win a few Super Bowls
I've always kind of wanted to be in the
front office my eventual goal is to be a
college football head coach hopefully a
full-time positional coaching job Phoebe
Schecter like many of the women here
plays tackle football after attending
the format 2017 she landed an internship
with the Buffalo Bills it makes you so
confident playing this sport and you're
you feel empowered and then you get to
come to something like this you've got
these other women who experience the
same things and you just think oh I can
conquer the world after this but you
know you almost hear like what football
you guys want to work in football
absolutely Stephanie Jackson is a wide
receiver for one of the 65 teams in the
women's football alliance it's
especially bad if you play because for
most people you have to beat them for
them to believe you football is to me
the best bit of every other sport Oh
putting together
Heather Marini has played in coached
football in Australia for ten years
football is kind of under siege in some
areas these days but we are here talking
about football is actually a thing of
the future youth football is very
inclusive there's a lot of sports where
you do have to be the fastest or the the
most athletic person but to play
football you know you can all shapes and
sizes can play I don't see football
going anywhere honestly especially
because women are when women get
something this is how it is you know
outside the forum you could see the
passion these young girls feel for the
game
and for the newly-crowned flag football
champions from Tucson Arizona the
message that girls are welcome in
football is being heard loud and clear
anybody would say girls can't play
football what would you guys say watch
me now some people may say how can women
coach football if they never even played
the sport but you know some of the best
coaches never played their sport either
and it's not just professional football
there are representatives from other
professional sports leagues like Major
League Baseball that are talking to the
NFL about how they can do this same kind
of forum in their sports scale all right
Jay and I say we got to remember Paula
Stephanie Heather and Phoebe to see
where they are years from now to say we
remember you guys in Jan Crawford's
piece can't wait to see where they end
up absolutely thank you very much Dan
Crawford